i'm tyrus i'm liz clayman i'm greg
jarrett and
this is the fox news rundown
friday may 21st 2021 i'm chris foster
turning the corner on coronavirus i
don't have a real good
picture for what the future looks like
for for every industry
but i know jamie dimon is a really smart
guy from jp morgan and two weeks ago he
told the wall street journal that he
believes
by october everything will look normal
everything will be normal it will be as
if it never happened
we speak with fox news channel host bill
hemmer i'm lisa brady
each side of the aisle in washington is
under pressure
from within their own party or are they
the reality is that a party that is
pretty aligned with
donald trump is a party that's pretty
aligned with where
republican voters are at when we look at
the numbers in terms of
democrats critical of president biden
which would indicate a split
on the left that the media should be
attending to it's just not there
and i'm joe koncha i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
people are in control of protecting
themselves and other unvaccinated people
from coronavirus now
27 states never put mass mandates in
place but 14 states with them announced
that they'd be relaxed immediately
within a few weeks when guidance from
the centers for disease control came out
that fully vaccinated people were mostly
safe to go massless
one of those states new york dropped its
mass mandate on wednesday
new york city was one of the first and
hardest hit cities during the early days
of the pandemic
there have been more than 33 000 coronal
virus deaths reported there businesses
had been closed and limited in capacity
those restrictions are now lifted and
the city is buzzing again
just not quite as loudly as before yet
there's a new vibe in the city
i think traffic has returned bill hammer
hosts america's newsroom
weekday mornings on fox news channel not
fully but it's i mean
you it feels like new york again i think
the neighborhoods are
actually quite advanced i think midtown
lags and that will be a lagging
indicator for a long time i think
because
there's so many skyscrapers here that
have empty tenant space
and i don't know what these companies
are going to do when they bring people
back
and every company it seems is a little
different from the other so that's
that's going to take some time you've
been working in the office
i have not um like you mentioned work
could be or
you alluded to at least work could be
different for a lot of people they who
are seeing the benefits of maybe not
spending so much time commuting
um or choice and flexibility about where
they live i wonder how much of that
sticks i guess it'll be industry by
industry
i don't have a real good picture for
what the future looks like for
for every industry but i know jamie
dimon's a really smart guy from jp
morgan and two weeks ago he told the
wall street journal that he believes
by october everything will look normal
everything will be normal it will be as
if it never happened
that is an extraordinary statement i
don't know if he's right um but that's
where his head is today
well it sounds fair i mean not to keep
this conversation completely new york
city-centric but by then
uh broadway shows will have been the
last thing
really to be open fully so maybe in
october maybe that's it
maybe maybe maybe things have just
snapped
it could be uh let's california look new
york was
pretty much behind a lot of different
states across the country and now
california is behind new york
california is not going to get rid of
the mask at least until we get into the
month of june as of today based on their
guidance
with respect to broadway broadway could
be open
today based on the guidelines but the
production is going to take some time to
get up to speed
hence the reason why it's going to be
september or october before
the theater district opens and i tell
you if you came to new york right now
and you drove around the theater
district
it is an absolute ghost town i mean
restaurant after restaurant and bar
after bar and hotel after hotel and
theater after block
after block there's there's been nothing
moving there now start the change is
starting to come out of their shell
um but that that will be i guess yeah i
guess that will be the last
leg the fall uh with regard to new york
we surprised at how quickly things
changed after the cdc guidance on mass
changed last week
even states like new york that had been
taking the pandemic very seriously from
early on immediately said okay that's it
if you've been vaccinated we're going to
follow this guidance now and the masks
and mostly go if you're vaccinated
i was shocked at how quickly it happened
in some of these states it was like they
flipped a switch
you know you went to bed on monday and
you woke up on tuesday in a different
place
you know i went to florida about two
months ago spent 10 days down there
and i just no one was wearing masks the
restaurants were packed
and i was fine with all of that so much
of the lifestyle is outdoors
there was no social distancing i i was
okay florida did it differently and
i it just it gave me a reminder of
everything that we have given up
and i am so happy that so many of us can
get part of that back now if not
all of it very soon there's still quite
a bit of
vaccine hesitancy more than i thought i
thought there would be initially and
then when people saw hey it seems to be
working nobody
you know people aren't dropping dead in
the street from the vaccine
but some people say nope i'm never ever
ever going to get it but i guess we're
just
we're going to reach the point where
okay it's your personal responsibility
yeah a personal decision i do agree with
the last point on that yeah
i was one of those who was like man i'm
not necessarily jumping in the line
first here to get the shots
um two things changed my mind i watched
how it was rolled out late december into
january
and then there's a doctor who works at
fox dr mark segal and he's been studying
pandemics for 20 years
he's written books on it fiction and
non-fiction alike he's written
books of fiction about pandemics that
never happened it's just stuff he pulled
out of his own brain
so i've relied on his counsel a lot
during the last 15 months or so
and he's convinced that it's the single
greatest vaccine that humankind has ever
created and it's the safest
and with regard to efficacy i haven't
had a flu shot in 20 years
but i i never stopped to think about how
effective a flu shot was before and now
i understand it's between 30 and 60
percent
well these are well above 90 percent
which is just phenomenal
it's the best most effective vaccine
that humankind has ever made
the second thing that convinced me is
that i i do believe over the next year
if you're going to want to travel
out of this country you're going to have
to prove that you got the jabs
and therefore you're going to have to
have the card
that's legitimate that shows that you
have been fully vaccinated
because of those two reasons i went i
went to the hospital sooner than i would
have thought
and i haven't regretted it there's a
dispute over masked rules in the house
chamber
republicans are saying they should be
dropped due to these cdc guidelines
however we do not know exactly who among
these republicans have been vaccinated
and how speaker nancy pelosi says nope
the rules stay until everybody's
vaccinated which of course could mean
forever
so to the very end of this masks are
still a political symbol
a couple things run through my mind i
understand what you say not everybody's
vaccinated here i think 75 percent of
the
republicans in the house have said
they've gotten the shot which leaves you
25
percent but medical experts and i think
the cdc would say that's that's still
okay
um especially for those who have been
vaccinated you're going to be safe and
clean
the the effect of that is that she's
already fined four members of the
republican party
five hundred dollars comes right out of
their paycheck and they've given
warnings
as of today i believe to eight others if
you get a second fine that goes up to
twenty five hundred dollars
and we spoke with a woman from iowa
she's a
member of the um republican delegation
and she said
listen i'm a doctor too i've studied
this stuff i'm okay
we should not have a mandate on the
floor of the house
and she insists that she she's not going
to put it back on even though she has
already paid
her 500 well let's wait and see what
happens when that goes to 2500 who else
is slapped with that and what
what happens as a result but even here
in new york there was
you know some major companies um that
you know ours
included that pretty much said as of may
20th that we were going to be okay
in our office spaces to not wear a mask
so yet again another layer that is
peeling away
i'm not quite sure where the debate ends
up in congress
uh but there's clearly a level of
disagreement as of now
i was reading a study that i thought was
at least interesting i don't know
exactly what it says
about us but this poll in the united
kingdom where there is
there have been people throughout the
pandemic that are reluctant to wear a
mask they don't want to do it
but there's zero correlation to their
political party
at all it doesn't matter who who they
vote for
or you know conservative liberal it's
just even across the board the
percentage of people
who say they don't want to wear a mask
we here are more into our team
than they may be in the united states
very interesting your observation may be
pretty pretty accurate um
i wore mine to keep myself safe and to
keep my family safe and my colleagues
and
um i i did it to be a to be a good and
cooperating citizen
i i i can understand perhaps there are
political differences but
uh in what they are rooted i do not know
other than to say that government cannot
tell me what to do
i will say this um i've been to a lot of
communist countries growing up and
through a lot of my own personal travel
and professional travel during my life
soviet union cuba
um a few others eastern europe and you
can see during the pandemic when the
government tells you something to do day
after day week after week and then month
after month that went into more than a
year
of commands and demands how beaten down
you can get
because your behavior changes and you
adapt and you all right you say i got to
do it okay i'll do it
well imagine what would happen if a
government a communist government
told their citizens what to do year not
month after
year over year decade over
decade you would you would find yourself
to be subservient to the state
and i i've seen that play out in a way
that i think
shows us a little bit about how that
history
had developed over time in some of the
countries i just mentioned
we talked last time a few months ago
about getting back to taking trips you
mentioned went to florida i've been to
florida myself through this uh
a few months ago my only trip during the
pandemic my only time on a plane during
the pandemic it was weird i still
haven't
been back to a restaurant uh inside mask
list yet have you
how did it feel was it strange wow great
question uh you haven't been on a plane
i have been on one plane i took i
actually took a train
to florida and a plane back wow uh must
have been a heck of a train ride so
so lovely there in the southeast i have
flew a lot during covid i felt very good
about it
i'm a delta diva so i always fly delta
i thought they were very good about
keeping middle seats open and not
packing the plane
they do require you to wear the mask i
was okay with that
sometimes i wore too just to be safe
because i'm not quite sure what was
floating around that
uh the inside of that cabin but i was
comfortable with it
um our team and we've been waiting to do
this
not everybody but we grabbed a few folks
and were able to head out to a local
restaurant here
in midtown middle of the day and we all
sat around a table
nobody wore a mask and nobody thought
twice about it
and to me that's a really good sign
about normalcy coming back to a lot of
people's lives
bill hammer co-host america's newsroom
mornings on fox news channel with dana
perino how's dana these days by the way
i really enjoy working with her she
brought jasper to the set this week so
that was kind of exciting
uh because we did a little show outside
to show the reopening of new york
she's great love to work with her great
attitude
positive all the time and has a lot to
say bill good to talk to you thanks
you too thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming up
some of what happened in the u.s house
this week is emblematic of larger
debates
simmering in both parties two bills
stemming from the deadly capital riot
are heading to the u.s senate but facing
an uncertain fate
after house debate that got emotional
and political
a 1.9 billion dollar measure to boost
capital security
passing by just one vote thursday the
funding will respond to
the cost to harden the capital
to repair the capital and then to harden
against future attacks
house speaker nancy pelosi had several
defections in her own party mainly
over broader concerns about policing
republicans had concerns about the cost
and washington congresswoman jamie
herrera butler argued the bill should
have included
police leadership reform that's part of
the problem here that's part of the
problem with this bill
is we're putting the money there but
we're not reforming the system
the bill includes security measures like
retractable fencing and a rapid response
force
also providing extra security for
members of congress
in d.c and at home and for federal
judges who've also faced threats as
rioters are prosecuted
a bill that would create an independent
commission to study the capital breach
won more bipartisan support over 30
republicans joining democrats to back it
but the house and senate minority
leaders did not criticizing the process
and calling it a political commission
democrats accused them of politicizing
it and of caving to former president
trump
who calls the commission a democrat trap
i think republicans
have an opportunity to
try to make the case that they would
like to get to the bottom
of what happened on january 6. kristen
soltis anderson is a republican
pollster and fox news contributor and
you know for many republicans
those who have said look i i think this
has been spun out of proportion by the
media et cetera
in my view this commission would be a
perfect way to get
real facts out there to have republican
voices at the table
in the fact-finding process and so you
know
i think that's part of why you saw 35
republicans
sort of break with leadership and decide
to vote for the commission
i mean the president former president um
came out pretty swiftly released a
statement
knocking those 35 house republicans who
voted in favor of the commission
do republicans take a risk by
challenging him
certainly for any republican that sort
of
takes a step that president trump
doesn't like there is always the risk of
backlash because by
and large republicans are pretty unified
in saying
either that they believe donald trump
should be the leader of the party or by
saying
even if they don't think donald trump
should be the leader of the party that
they nonetheless still like him
that there's not a ton of appetite in
the party for
disagreement uh breaking with party
leadership um
what's kind of fascinating is that at
one point in time about 10 years ago
with the rise of the tea party
you had the grassroots really in a
position of saying look
we want our members we don't care about
party unity we want folks to stand on
principle
and now it's almost as though that
shifted a little bit where
some of those very same folks would say
no right now the most important thing
for fighting democrats is staying
unified rather than being distracted
and in some ways it's the more moderate
members who are the ones saying
no no i don't want to just go along with
party unity i'm the one that's going to
try to stand up on my own principles
the dynamic has shifted quite a bit over
the last decade
the 2022 midterms feel closer all the
time
from a political standpoint somehow how
much of the gop
infighting is just media hype though is
it something that the media is really
playing up more than reality
yeah i think in general you know if i go
do a survey of republican voters
while there is going to be you know
maybe one in six who say
you know i really don't like president
trump and i really don't like the
direction of the party
that's a pretty small portion and i
think you know ultimately if you turn
on you know the mainstream news that
one-sixth of the party gets
about fifty percent of the coverage so
you know it's certainly a pr
a presence within the party but most of
the party is pretty unified behind the
idea that they liked the job
president trump had done they wish he'd
won the election and they're looking for
republicans to be unified moving forward
so i think sometimes the gop civil war
well
there is real disagreement within even
you know party voters about how the
party should be thinking about
say the role of president trump moving
forward i think that disagreement gets
really amplified in the coverage
and the percentage of republicans who
want to go a different direction
kind of get over-represented in the
coverage
one of the frequent republican arguments
is
democrat hypocrisy and they point to
things like
president biden cancelling the keystone
pipeline but then not trying to block a
russian
pipeline to germany is that gaining
traction with voters beyond the
republican base
well at the moment joe biden and his
administration
i would call their poll ratings fine
they're not great
at the moment a lot of voters have
simply just tuned out of politics
you've seen things like the very low
ratings that biden's address to the
joint session of congress
uh got you know fairly low ratings
compared to both former presidents trump
and obama people have just kind of tuned
it out
so i think stories like this for your
true swing voter
it's we're too far out from the midterms
for them to have tuned in
but the downside for democrats is that
republicans still remain pretty tuned in
and fired up
pretty engaged fundraising is really
high for republican groups
where for democrats it's as though they
won in 2020 and they're now resting on
their laurels a little bit they're not
terribly fired up by what's going on in
washington
and i think with president trump taking
a little bit less
of the national spotlight they've sort
of
become much more content the house
speaker
says republicans need to take back their
party
is it possible for republicans to unify
as long as the former president
is in the mix i think the idea of taking
back their party i mean
donald trump won the republican
nomination and
it wasn't just you know i think at the
time there was offense so maybe it was a
kind of a a blip that you know it was
like a perfect storm of things that
enabled him to rise but
republicans by and large liked the
tenure that trump had in office they
liked that four years they wanted four
more years of it
he won unbelievably high percentage of
republicans
in the presidential election so the idea
of trying to
take their party back i mean the reality
is that a party that is pretty aligned
with donald trump
is a party that's pretty aligned with
where republican voters are at
the bigger challenge for republicans is
to what extent is that going to have
appeal with swing voters in the election
and that's why i think you're going to
see them sort of understanding that
trump is a little less popular among
swing voters
but the democratic agenda they can
really go after and say here's what we
want to be a check and balance against
i expect you'll see that become more of
the message coming out of republicans
when they begin talking more and more to
swing voters in the months to come
democrats have had some infighting too
including over the recent fighting
between
israel and palestinian militants in gaza
president biden facing progressive
pressure to support palestinian citizens
more
after expressing support for israel's
right to defend itself well i think that
it creates a dilemma for president biden
juan williams is a democratic strategist
and co-host of the five on fox news
channel
clearly the united states is an ally of
israel
and a long-standing friend but i think
that what we're
experiencing is a big change in terms of
public
attitudes in the united states towards
israel
this is the first time that i can
remember that israel is involved in a
conflict
in the age of social media so
a lot of voices are being heard who
might have been ignored before
and right now you also have the
political overlay that
prime minister netanyahu had a very
close relationship with president trump
he relies on several
key republican donors he did not have a
good relationship with president
obama even came to speak to the congress
at the invitation of republicans
not the president that was unprecedented
at the time
and so i think that prime minister
netanyahu
is unaware of how the politics now
is starting to color america's love for
israel and i don't think he
anticipated that there could be such a
strong
sense that you know israel is the
stronger hand here
as compared to the palestinians and you
would even have
bernie sanders the senator from vermont
a jewish american
suggesting that the united states
withhold
arms sales to israel what about the left
on other issues and i ask because you
know moderate democrats
law seats in the 2020 election um but
now we've had some progressives say
they've been pleasantly surprised
by the way that this president has
governed so far
um if he's behaving more progressively
than some expected could that
hurt democrats in the 2022 midterms
well i think that's the republican
critique and
you know you don't have to go too far to
hear republicans say
that the democrats are overrun with
socialist
and that joe biden and his effort in
terms of the
release package for the pandemic and now
the infrastructure deal that this
is introducing socialism to america so i
think that's the standard republican
critique
so far we don't see it in the poll
numbers
what we see in fact is support not only
for bybe his approval rating is pretty
high
but support for the infrastructure
spending plan which is of course in the
trillions of dollars it's unbelievable
what if he's able to
find common ground with republicans on a
bipartisan
infrastructure deal would he then pay a
price
and lose support with progressives
this is a two-part question actually
because
one of the ideas being put forward uh
notably by senator shelly moore capito
of west virginia
is that you could divide the
infrastructure bill into two parts
and you could get bipartisan republican
and democratic support for that first
part
uh and then the president might you know
go after
a second infrastructure bill with things
that
he doesn't have bipartisan support for
that might include for example
child care is that infrastructure biden
says it is it's necessary for women to
get to work
but many republicans say they want steel
and concrete
and you know tar on their infrastructure
products
so it's possible that he gets bipartisan
support for the first part of this via
lisa
and not for the second and that's the
way they're looking at it right now
is there a chance that the media
which sometimes gets criticism from both
sides of the aisle
um would rather focus on the problems in
the republican party
than the problems president biden could
face within his own party
do you see any you know unbalance any
disparity there
right now i think there's a lot of
criticism of the media coming from the
right
they see the media you know along with
hollywood as the elites and all that
but when we look at the numbers in terms
of
democrats critical of president biden
which would indicate a split on the left
that the media should be attending to
it's just not there biden has almost
no i think it's more than 90 percent
support among democrats in the country
so he's doing pretty well there at the
moment uh you know the argument from the
right
is that so some on the left have quieted
their criticism
of biden uh in order to have a
democratic president
now from on the right you clearly have a
civil war going on
in terms of president trump versus
liz cheney the congresswoman from
wyoming
and it's pretty much out in the open
given that cheney lost her leadership
spot in the house
republican caucus and president trump is
out there
making it very clear he doesn't like liz
cheney he doesn't like anybody
who's challenging him so uh one is
you know kind of up in the ear for all
to see and the other for the moment
is there but it's not as visible because
democrats are maintaining united front
juan williams so nice to talk to you
thanks lisa
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a california teen is sweetening the
lives of others
one bite at a time vedica jawa was just
15 years old when her family trip to san
francisco
planted a seed in her mind that's grown
into a mission
the associated press reports that when
she saw people living on the streets
during that trip
she returned to her home in fremont
california decided to do something to
help them
she reached out to homeless shelters and
offered to bake treats for the residents
some of the people in charge told her
she was too young others just ignored
her
but she persisted she started with a
neighborhood bake sale
and collected ingredients at her school
then finally got a shelter to allow her
to bake for the people who were staying
there
it was the beginning of her student-run
non-profit called
bake forsake which distributes desserts
to those in need
over the last year and a half the
project has gone from a handful of
friends who helped out with the baking
in her hometown
to more than a hundred volunteers who
now work with 15 homeless shelters in 10
locations nationwide
the bake forsake instagram page says the
project has now served more than
17 thousand desserts to the homeless
community
vadika says she hopes to see it grow
even more with people opening their own
bake for sake chapters
especially during this time of illness
job loss and business closures that have
created greater food insecurity
she says quote we think that a simple
act of kindness can go a long way for
someone who is facing such a difficult
time
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe koncha what's on your mind
if you watch abc cbs nbc or cnn
you likely have been bombarded over the
last month about a republican
civil war starring liz cheney the media
it girl that everyone is making out to
be the next wonder woman
bravely taking on the powerful in her
own party in a non-stop campaign to stop
the 45th president
who by the way isn't in office instead
of focusing on the current occupant
in joe biden but we're not talking about
this civil war
we're talking about the one on the
democratic side that you're not hearing
about
over the president's handling or
non-handling of the israeli-palestinian
conflict
congresswoman rashida talib confronted
joe biden
on a michigan tarmac recently over it
particularly around support for
israel how dare he this comes after
congresswoman and mideast
policy expert alexander love fox news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes